at this
very moment with every breath
we take major delta cities
across the globe are sinking including
new york london tokyo shanghai
new orleans and as well as my city
bangkok here
is the usual version of climate change
this is mine nothing much just crocodile
on the street
this is an urgent impact of climate
change
oversinking cities
here you can see urbanization of bangkok
growing in every direction
shifting from porous agricultural land
the land can breathe and absorb water
to a concrete jungle
this is part of it look like after 30
minutes of rainfall
and every time it rains i wish my car
could turn into
a boat this land has no room for water
it has lost its absorbent capacity
the reality of bangkok metropolitan
region is
a city of 15 million
people living working and commuting
on top of shifting muddy river delta
bangkok is sinking more than one
centimeters per year
which is four times faster
than the rate of predicted sea level
rise
and we could be below sea level by
2030 which will be here too soon
there was no coincidence that
i am here as a landscape architect
as a child i grew up in a row house
next to the busy road always filled with
traffic
in front of my house there was a
concrete parking lot
and that was my playground
the only living creature i
would find and had fun with were
these sneaky little plants trying to go
through the crack
of the concrete pavement my favorite
games with friends
was to dig the bigger and the bigger
hole
through this crack to let this little
plant
creep out sneak out more and more
and yes landscape architecture
gives me the opportunity to continue my
cracking
ambition to connect this concrete land
back to nature
before thais my people
we were adapted to the cycle of the wet
and dry season and you could call
us amphibious we live both on land
and on water we were adapted
to both and flooding was a happy event
when the water fertilized our land
but now flooding means
disaster 2011
thailand was hit by the most damaging
and the most
expensive flood disaster in our history
flooding has turned central thailand
into an enormous lake
here you can see the scale of the flood
in the center of the image
to the scale of bangkok outlined in
yellow
the water was overflowing from the north
making its way
across several provinces
millions of my people
including me and my family
were displaced and homeless
some have to escape the city
many were terrified of losing their home
and their belongings
so they stay back in the flood with no
electricity
and clean water
for me this thought reflects clearly
that
our modern infrastructure
and especially our notion of fighting
flood
with concrete had made us so
extremely vulnerable to the climate
uncertainty
but in the heart of this disaster
i found my calling i cannot just sit
and wait as my city continues to sink
the city needed me and i have ability
to fix this problem
six years ago i started my project
my teams and i won the design
competition
for shula long gone centenary park
this was the big bow mission of the
first
university in thailand for celebrating
its
100th anniversary by
giving this piece of land as a public
park to our city
having a park sounds very normal
to many other cities but not
in bangkok which has
one of the lowest public green space
per capita among mega city in asia
our projects become the first new public
park
in almost 30 years the 11 acres park
a big green crack at the heart of
bangkok
opened just last year
thank you
for four years we have pushed through
countless meetings to convince and never
giving up to convince
that this park isn't just for
beautification
or recreation it must help the city deal
with water
it must help the city confront climate
change
and here is how it works bangkok is a
flat city
so we harness the power of gravity by
incline the whole park
to collect every drop spring
the gravity force pull down the runoff
from the highest point
to the lowest point this park has three
main elements that
work as one system the first the green
roof
this is the biggest green roof in
thailand
with the rain water tanks and museum
underneath
in the dry season the collected rain
can be used to water the park up to
a month the runoff on the green roof
then fall through wetlands
with the native water plants that can
help filter
and help clean water and
at the lower end the retention pond
collects all of the water
at this pond there are water bikes
people can pedals and help clean water
the exercise becomes an active part
of the park water system
when life gives you flood you have fun
with the water
centenary park gives room for people and
room for water
which is exactly what we and our cities
need
this is an amphibious
design this park is not about getting
rid
of flood it's about creating a way
how we can live with it and not a single
drop sprain
is wasted in this park
this park can hold and collect
a million gallons of water
thank you
[Music]
every given project for me is an
opportunity
to create more green cracks to this
concrete jungle
by using landscape architecture as
solution
like turning this concrete blue
to an urban farm which can help
absorb rain reduce urban heat island
and grow food in the middle of the city
reuse the abandoned concrete structure
to become a green pedestrian bridge
and another fast-proof park at thomassod
university which nearly completes the
biggest
green roof in academic campus
yet in southeast asia
severe flooding is our new normal
pudding southeast asia region
the region with the most coastline
at extreme risk
creating a park is just one solution
the awareness of climate change means we
in every profession we are involved
are increasingly obligated to understand
the climate risk
and put whatever we are working on
as part of the solution
because if our city
continues the way they are now
the similar catastrophe will happen
again
and again
creating a solution in these sinking
cities
is like making impossible
possible and for that
i would like to share one word that i
always keep in mind that is
literal translation for tang is
to firmly stand
and for jai means heart
firmly stand your heart at your goal
in thai language when you commit to do
something
you put danger in front of your word
so your heart will be in your
action no matter how rough the path
how big the crack you push to your goal
because just where your heart is
and yes thailand is home
this land is my only home
and that's where i
firmly stand my heart where do you stand
yours
thank you thank you